so there were a lot of favorite
candidates to win the succession war
like you've got first Prince Benjamin
and his personal army Camilla and her
unkillable nature and there's even Zhang
lei who has some well he has coins I
guess however my favorite candidate by
far would be 4th Prince subscribe nick
who has the ability to allow you to
subscribe to the new order view for
regular Hunter hunter content uploaded
straight into your YouTube feed hello
and welcome to the new order view your
source for everything anime and manga
and more specifically welcome very sadly
the final hunter hunter auch review
where today we will be taking a look at
what we can of the most current arc in
the series being the succession war the
succession war is the ninth arc in the
series consisting of currently 42
chapters and a total of 0 anime episodes
very sad and not a huge amount of hope
in regards to the latter to come for an
awfully awfully long time but the
succession war is where we currently
find ourselves invested in the series
however due to its ongoing nature it's
not really possible to review it as we
have done with every previous arc due to
not having the full scope of Takashi's
plans let alone technical implementation
but we'll do the best we can with what
we have what I will save for the 42
chapters that we have read in this arc
is that these are some of the most
gripping pieces of story then hunter
hunter has ever produced in my opinion
untalented to me has a very typically
slow start to many arcs well you just
need to kind of let Takashi do his thing
and build up before the narrative
substance really starts to take effect
the prime example of which would be the
chimera Hawk but it's also very present
in york-new city in greed Island as well
however from the get-go I have been
completely on board with and enthralled
by the succession war and I put a lot of
that down to the format of the contest
as I've said many times death games are
well they're my jam however they only
operate at full effect with a brilliant
cast of characters and thankfully this
arc presents us with a grand total of 14
wonderfully written and presented well
for the most part princes to follow into
battle and it's actually kind of amazing
just how compelling these figures are
and yes I will say that that is not
necessarily apparent on first
read-through for reasons that we will
get in shortly but every major competing
Prince carries with them a unique
perspective and drive to win this
contest
which can range from shallow desires of
power to stall what opposition of an
establishment system of cocking
governance and then all the way to
twisted murders pursuit of the arts and
regards that loss factor I'll just say
right here and now that 4th Prince
radnik is currently the character who
has had by far the most impact on me
during the sock which is pretty damn
impressive considering the extensive
constable at the black whale 1 and
what's more is that I do
thank him at all it's more that I have
this morbid fascination with his
existence and the atmosphere that his
presence brings to the series because
everytime cirrhotic shows up in a
chapter he makes you pay attention like
there's a lot that can get lost in the
succession war as portrayed in the manga
but serene ik is like a jolt of caffeine
because he is becoming an increasingly
more terrifying threat and he has me
legitimately worried about every
character within his immediate vicinity
which is mostly theta
poor poor theta but even though the sock
is still in a developmental phase I
would say that there is no doubt that's
right nick is being built up as the
primary antagonist shining like Aramis
sinister star carving his presence as a
front-runner for the contest next most
appealing Prince to me would be Hawking
Berg though I do very much appreciate
that he is probably the only figure who
comes into this event with something of
a relatable moral compass I mean he
certainly does have his flaws and I
think that his eventual corruption is
going to play into the arc but Holcomb
Berg was more or less pacifist with
strong opposition to the way in which
the cockin we're a family currently
rules their kingdom so when any other
typical story Hulkenberg would probably
be seen as the good guy but he has
started on a dangerous path now coming
to accept the conditions of the death
match and abandoning his previous
pacifist ideology and that's very much
why I'm so fascinated by him because he
shows the most potential for growth and
intrigue amongst all the princes even so
right now but we should also not neglect
to mention that not every part has been
in the succession war has grand dreams
of power or form and they are in fact an
entire contingent of princes who want
nothing more than to be able to live in
peace a great example of this would be
forget to encontró rue during this war
have only been focused on keeping each
other alive and rather tragically so but
I want to highlight this because there
is a wide array of the human spectrum on
display amongst each of the 14th
Prince's and while I don't have time to
go into them all individually they are
all very much worth closer examination
but without aside I think we do need to
discuss the more controversial aspect of
this arc now which does often impede
people's enjoyment of it being the
declining state of hunter hunter as a
manga now this is a topic that I haven't
covered within the arc review series and
maybe I should have but there has been a
very evident decline in artistic quality
from late great island to modern day
very inconsistent quality I should say
more accurately sometimes the odd is
great sometimes it's average and sadly
sometimes it's nothing more than a
glorified storyboard however the
succession will arc has taken this to a
whole new level and while the art is
generally consistent I guess
margarit self is produced on a very
minimalist regime often omitting
backgrounds and in
cases that our entire panels taken up by
text with no drawings whatsoever in fact
text itself has come to be defined is
probably the most dominant visual aspect
of the succession war ah and this is a
very conflicting feature so I'll say
straight up that I'm not going to go
into detail about Takashi's health
conditions or the reasoning behind Honda
Honda's aesthetic decline because for
the purposes of this review it's not so
important what is important is the end
result and overall impression of the art
and what I will say in favor of it is
that the succession war and the Dark
Continent petition arc actually saw
something of an increase in artistic
quality in select areas there are times
when you will look at a page of the
succession wall and it is stunning it
seems like a pure shot of classic
togarashi with well drawn characters and
some nice detail backgrounds although
some of that background work may be
attributable to assistants regardless of
that though this visual quality is not
consistent and there are other times
when the succession wall can really push
the limits of what can technically be
considered manga rather than a novel or
a light nor I should continue that whole
conversation with a positive in that
this story is brilliantly written
takashi has mastered the art of writing
political intrigue as well as presenting
logical and well characterized in a
monologues that do push the story
forward
if the succession war arc was a novel
then I would be praising it to no end
however it is a manga and considering
the format is very important because the
sheer dominance of text can make
chapters an incredible sulk to get
through at times and it's just that
thing you know the most important aspect
of any visual medium is the idea of you
show don't tell it's a saying that we've
all heard about billion times but that's
because 100 percent of history's
greatest visual media do adhere to this
philosophy and so Takashi's work with
the succession walks specifically is
very counterintuitive to the entire
manga media and they often see the
argument online of hood do just learn to
read Monsieur Lee knows stuff along
those lines but I don't think that's
fair
just because someone feels bulk down by
text when they've chosen to read a comic
does not make them lazy dumb or
unreasonable in fact the idea of it is
much more akin to sitting down to watch
movie just to have half of it be a
completely blank screen and just hearing
the sound alone they can still portray a
fine story but it was not the experience
of the medium that you expected and it
is very jarring so I can absolutely
understand the complaints behind the
succession walk and I do think it's a
shame because like I said there is so
much glorious substance at work here and
when you do take the time to sift
through it in detail it paints an
incredible setting with truly
captivating characters but a lot of that
just so happens to be buried with intact
so for this arc you do very much have to
embrace that but once you do it is a
great experience all right with that
discussion out of the way let's turn to
another highlight of the arc which is
our protagonist grafica this arc only
works because we have this character
there is no other protagonist who could
helm a story this complex which once
again shows the great advantage of
Takashi's choices in constructing hunter
hunter because if he stuck to a typical
Shonen format then he would more than
likely have to include gone as the
protagonist of this arc and as much as I
love gone he just does not belong here
at all this story could never been told
with him at the forefront and it demands
a character of crop because aptitude in
the lead and as the result the
succession war presents itself as a
radically different piece of story to
anything that we have seen prior in the
series and I suppose the arca would be
most comparable with would be york new
city because things got very
organizationally focused there as well
with the Mafia families and the fandom
troupe but this is on a whole different
level and I love it because it continues
to evolve Hunter hunter into an
unparalleled piece of storytelling and
that said we do find ourselves in a very
odd spot at the moment because we've
been on hiatus for a year at the time of
this recording and we've now begun the
inevitable thoughts of will this arc
ever continue let alone actually
conclude and look I haven't weathered
enough hiatuses personally to be any
expert on this but I feel like this line
of thinking emerges during every
extended period of downtime people lose
all hope and then out of nowhere al
Borden Savior Takashi trickles down some
morsels of a few chapters raining upon
us on washed masses which raises our
spirits briefly only to restart the
cycle so I personally do believe that
this arc will end although it will
undoubtedly be another massively long
piece of story second only to the
Chimera an talk because we're about 14
chapters away from surpassing york-new
City as it stands in terms of length and
about 24 away from beating creed island
and I'm not sure that I can see these
events being completed in that timeframe
the really strange thing is that in 42
chapters Takashi is still introducing
new characters and setting things up
rather than diving into what I would
describe as the pure meat of the story
so I very much do believe that we are
still in the introductory phase of the
succession wall and I think that we have
a very long long way to go once we get
there I'm sure that we will look back on
this arc very fondly and now I also want
to address an event that is technically
part of the succession walk which is the
fight between Hisoka and crawler you
know if it was me I would not consider
this part of the succession wall because
it is such an isolated narrative and I
think it really did need to be included
as part of Lost Ark but because it's
here I do need to mention that this is
my favorite fights in the entire series
despite the fact that crow lo clearly
dominates at the entire way this handful
of chapters is some of the most
compelling content I have ever laid eyes
on the action was stunning the ideas of
play were brilliant especially in
regards to how crawler utilized an
incredible combination of borrowed
abilities and the conclusion was
satisfying and exciting satisfying in
that Hisoka quite rightfully was beaten
and even killed but exciting because
this is Hisoka we're talking about and
he was able to engage in post-mortem
meant to revive himself thus becoming
the greatest threat that he has ever
been presented as in the series and in
general I'm just incredibly glad that he
Sokka and the Phantom troupe have such a
large threat in the succession war story
because it adds a wonderful element of
Anarchy into the mix plus it's just been
so damn long since we've seen the
Phantom troupe or even he's so current
primary focus and they are some of the
most interesting characters in the
series so I will never be complaining
with their involvement but really that's
all I can say in general terms about the
succession war as an arc yeah there's a
lot more to it like the cucking Mafia
families which I've exported other
videos as well as the presence of the
zodiacs and even LME zoldak all of which
is great setup and continues to have me
eagerly awaiting for the return of the
series but for the purpose of talking
about an arc here the most I can say is
that well they're there and I hopes that
they get used nicely so hopefully in the
future you'll find me remaking this
video with a much more well-rounded
perspective but for now all we can do is
wait but what do you guys think please
to leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server you
know if you came for some more hunt onto
content then please do go and check outs
on my other videos we'll even subscribe
to the channel for more hunt under glory
to live it straight into your YouTube
feed but for now this has been the new
world view and I'll see you next time